one of the challenges of face
recognition is that you need to solve
the one-shot learning problem what that
means is that for most face recognition
applications you need together recognize
a person given just one single image or
given just one example of that person's
face and historically deep learning
algorithms don't work well if you have
only one training example let's see an
example of what this means and then talk
about how to address this problem let's
say you have a database of four pictures
of employees in your organization these
are actually some of my colleagues at
debugging AI K and a neo Eunice and Tien
now let's say someone shows up at the
office and they want to be led through
the turnstile what the system has to do
is despite ever having seen only one
image of Danielle to recognize that this
is actually the same person and in
contrast if I see someone that's not in
this database then they should recognize
that this is not any of the four persons
in the database so the one-shot learning
problem you have to learn from just one
example to recognize the person again
and you need this for most face
recognition systems because you might
have only one picture of each of your
employees or if your team members in
your employee database so one approach
you could try is to input the image of
the person feed it to a confident and
have it out put a label why using a soft
max unit with four outputs or maybe five
outputs corresponding to each of these
four persons or none of the above so
that would be five outputs in the
softmax
but this really doesn't work well
because if you have such a small
training set is really not enough to
train a robust neural network for this
task and also whatever new person joins
your team so now you have five persons
you need to recognize so there should
now be six outputs do you have to
retrain the confident every time that
just doesn't seem like a good approach
so the carry outs face recognition
to carry out one-shot learning so
instead to make this work
what you're going to do instead is
learning similarity function in
particular you want a neural network to
learn a function which is going to
denote D which inputs two images and it
outputs the degree of difference between
the two images so if the two images are
of the same person you want to this to
output a small number and if the two
images are of two very different people
you wanted to output a large number
so during recognition time if the degree
of difference between them is less than
some threshold called tau which is a
parameter a hyper parameter then you
would predict that these two pictures
are of the same person and it is greater
than tau you would predict that these
are different persons and so this is how
you address the face verification
problem to use this for a recognition
task what you do is given this new
picture you would use this function D to
compare these two images and maybe I'll
output a very large number let's say 10
for this example and then you compare
this with the second image in your
database and because these two are the
same person hopefully your output is a
very small number and then you do this
for the other images in your database
and so on and based on this you will
figure out that this is actually that
person which is a danielle and in
contrast is someone not in your database
shows up as you use the function D to
make all of these pairwise comparisons
hopefully D will output a very large
number for all four pairwise comparisons
and then you say that this is not any
one of the four persons in the database
notice how this allows you to solve the
one-shot learning problem so long as you
can learn this function D which inputs a
pair of images and tells you basically
if they're the same
you know different persons then if you
have someone new join your team you can
add a fifth person to your database and
it just works fine so you've seen how
learning this function D which inputs to
images allows you to address the
one-shot learning problem in the next
video let's take a look at how you can
actually train in your network to learn
this function D